well sorta they got crafts forgetting a
handjob that was Florida - how stupid
krazy stoopid it's cool what we were
talking about it like how does he not
have a guy who get him jerked off like
there's probably a lot of gals out there
that would like to make some money you
know you don't have to go to a massage
parlor the biggest bummer of it is is
now my massage parlors closed down ah
that's the problem where do I go now
what's the cross where broke guys go is
well the fact that they were filming you
- it's so whole thing is so strange and
if there was human trafficking going on
there what what were cops chilling there
for like six months some ongoing
investigation
can you save these poor victims yeah but
human trafficking has become like this
keyword it's like this new sort of like
fear-mongering kind of a term to get
everybody all up in arms and now they're
kind of backtracking on that they're
like well maybe it wasn't exactly Oh
Travie maybe it was just a subtext
reason why he was a horrible person
because he was contributing to these
people that were essentially being sold
for sex slavery turns out that might
have been a bit overblown no pun
intended of overblown but of course
that's kind of how they have to sell it
right otherwise people like why are you
wasting all this money on hand jobs
no one can why because solving real
crime is hard and dangerous and
dangerous okay so you can go and pick
somebody up for marijuana or getting a
handjob whatever and you can look like
you're you're being proactive yeah but
solving a murder that's hard man that's
hard work hard dangerous and you know if
you go to a weird little asian massage
place and guys are coming out smiling
like hmm it's uh you can start there
yeah you know what low-hanging fruit
really no offense - there was a weird
law in Hawaii where they were letting
cops actually have sex with prostitutes
like to prove that they were prostitutes
I think nearly half the states in the
Union have a law that allow police
officers to have sex with people in
custody
what yeah really I can't make it how do
you make this shit up and they're saying
well it was consensual because it
consensual they're in fucking handcuffs
it's consensual like what that's human
trafficking if you ask me I mean well
yeah and obviously they're gonna try to
make deals hey I'll suck your dick if
you get me out of here
how was that how was that consensual
how's that legal it's crazy
it's the ultimate I mean you talk about
people holding power over people let's
keep Altima coerce consent absolutely
yeah I mean that is that is more than an
employer doing that to an employee I
mean you're literally dangling their
freedom talk about an abuse of power
seriously I just look I I have all
daughters I'm not I don't want anybody's
daughter to be a prostitute but I'm also
100% in favor of people being able do
whatever the fuck they want and if
someone's in a weird stage in their life
where they'd rather jerk guys off than
work at Denny's like who's anybody to
stop them from doing that the only
problem is the social stigma that's
attached to it the actual act itself is
it's beneficial though the person gets
something out of it you know I mean
there's it's some people have a really
hard time getting someone to have sex
with them you know it's I don't see it
that it's just a crazy thing that we
regulate something that I mean George
Carlin had a great bit about it that's
the only thing where it's illegal to
make someone pay for it but it's fine if
it's free like it literally doesn't make
sense there's nothing wrong with sex but
there's something wrong with people
paying for it and it's fine if you pay
for it and then videotape it for
distribution because then porn yeah I
don't really
first of all it's a contract between two
consenting adults if we if we're talking
about small government deregulation
let's allow two consenting adults to
engage in a contractual relationship yes
offer acceptance consideration as with
anything else a stigma as you mentioned
a lot of that is part and parcel of the
prohibition the illegality of it is what
brings the seediness
it's what brings the danger right
because it's forced underground you
introduce all of these elements that
don't have to be there they can take
place in clean environments they can
take place instead of in the black
market and underground it could take
place in a where you can protect all the
participants yes
involved and it's it but it's been true
of liquor it's been true of marijuana
it's been true of prostitution which
they call for a reason the oldest
profession yeah
ii we introduced the prohibition it
creates a level of danger and a threat
to society that wouldn't exist if you're
like we'll wait what if you just let me
smoke this what if you just let me drink
this because I'm an adult making a
responsible decision for myself what if
you just let me engage in sexual
activity with this person who is
perfectly willing to do it in exchange
for some Renu Maury ssin yeah what the
why should anybody give a shit it's so
pure tan